informeer van bbp
dank u wel voorzitter
ik zou graag van de minister horen of wij niet gewoon
eerst dit gesprek over de ruimte
eens 1 keer moeten voeren
over de ruimte in Nederland
en dan pas GA praten over
wat kan wel waar en wat niet
want die dozen worden
natuurlijk niet meer zo neergezet om te gebruiken
dus die vervullen ergens 1 functie
ik weet ook niet of de minister weet in welke mate
dit voor binnenlandse distributie is
in welke mate dit te maken heeft met
onze positie als doorvoerpunt
vanuit onze havens
is daar zicht op
jazeker
daar is heel goed zicht op en het is beide waard
en voor binnenland
en voor doorvoer
maar ook voor doorvoer is het de vraag
of het allemaal in Nederland moet
waarom moet het allemaal langs de a15
er staan toch behoorlijke dozen langs de a15
waar ze in Duitsland geen trek in hebben
daar hebben ze toch echt meer ruimte
voor dit soort dozen
dan bij ons dus
het enkele feit dat dat ook voor doorvoer bedoeld is
Wil niet zeggen dat het allemaal
hier moet plaatsvinden
en natuurlijk
moeten we dat gesprek over de ruimte voeren
dat voeren we dus ook in de nota ruimte
en die nota ruimte kon in 1 voorontwerp naar de kamer
toen nog voor de zomer
om dan
toe te werken naar 1 daadwerkelijke ontwerpnota ruimte
voor het einde van het jaar
en die zullen wij hier dan in de kamer
gaan behandelen
volgens mij is er in juni ook 1 debat
hier over de ruimtelijke ordening
en laten we al dit type facetten
van de ruimtelijke ordening
dan langslopen
dat is ongelooflijk belangrijk
wat we zien is
de ruimte is ongelooflijk schaars
en eigenlijk alle ontwikkelingen
waar we middenin zitten
de circulaire economie
waar mevrouw welzijn het over had
duurzame energieopwekking
waar we het heel vaak over hebben
maar ook de verstedelijking
met de demografische groei die we hebben
alle ontwikkelingen waar we middenin zitten
vragen om meer ruimte en niet om minder
en meer ruimte is er niet
we kunnen geen land bij maken
niet meer in ieder geval
dus meer ruimte is er niet
dus we moeten leren kiezen
en daar zijn we eigenlijk
niet zo heel erg goed in de laatste tijd
ja dank u wel voorzitter
nog 1 vraag weet de minister ook waarom het
ondanks dat de grond hier zo duur is
arbeidsgaas is het
waarom toch zo aantrekkelijk is voor bedrijven om
deze dozen nou juist hier neer te zetten in plaats van
wat u al zegt
in de ruimte in Duitsland bijvoorbeeld
1 van de redenen
is dat je hier natuurlijk in het logistieke
centrum van Europa zit
dat is 1 van de redenen
tweede reden is
dat we hier veel te weinig restructief
zijn ten aanzien van onze ruimtelijke ordening
dat is echt 1/2 reden
en daarom moeten we veel restructiever worden